97 federal judges confirmed under Joe
Biden total number of white men five
22 are black women
so this is race-based hiring it's
illegal but it's also not about looking
like America it's about punishing people
now that could not be less true and what
Tucker Carlson doesn't tell you when he
says well hold on a second
97 federal judges confirmed under Biden
22 were black women that's like almost a
quarter that doesn't make any sense that
doesn't look like America but you have
to zoom out and you have to realize
there are currently about 1400 sitting
federal judges 1400 exactly
1407 more than half are white men not
just white more than half are white men
and only four and a half percent are
black women